on l'a vu à l'énoncé du verdict la mère
de patrick dils n'arrivait plus à cacher
son émotion partagée entre accablement
et incompréhension aujourd'hui ses
proches se sont retrouvés au domicile
familial alors que les effets personnels
du condamné avaient déjà été rapatriés
de la présente de façon donc très
prématuré jérôme soûlard et sylvain
gauthier durée décevant un difficile
retour de procès pour la famille 10 14
ans d'espoir de procédure pour rien car
ce soir patrick dort toujours en prison
vide sa chambre d'enfant n'a pas bougé
seule nouveauté ces quelques affaires
que patrick dils a récemment envoyé de
sa cellule comme ça ils étaient contents
que ça sera déjà ça de moi à sortir le
jour de sa libération
mais enfin il y avait quand même de bons
éléments dans le dossier dans le dossier
comme le procès était étalé on pensait
que toute la lumière sera faite
hélas hélas pour patrick dils il fait
aujourd'hui un nouvel anniversaire
enfermé portes il ya encore une fois en
prison
et puis nous ben on peut rien faire on
est de notre côté tout seul seuls nice
pour la famille disent les audiences ont
été éprouvantes car patrick a une fois
encore beaucoup peiné à expliquer à se
défendre ils n'arrivent pas à s'exprimer
ils se bloquent mais le peu de choses
qu'il a dit c'est des choses qu'ils ont
vraiment apporté énormément on s'exprime
pas beaucoup une phrase ça englobe à
chapitre à patrick dit qu'il est
innocent parce qu'il est vraiment
innocent pour lui les crimes dits pense
qu'il n'a pas besoin d'expliquer en long
et en large il faut trouver le vrai
criminel et ne pas laisser à ninon sont
aux prisons du réalité carriera reims
patrick a été condamné à 25 ans
d'enfermement
après délibéré schuller le choc pour une
deuxième fois nous est tombé sur la tête
ce soir la famille deal c'est
terriblement déçu les certainement pas
résigné après 14 années de combat
judiciaire
ils sont décidés encore à se battre
jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à l'acquittement